hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome to today's video you know
today's video I'm going to talk about
the mees Futures versus the es Futures
and you know cuz one of the questions I
get is you know should I trade Mees or
should I trade es and I sort of want to
break it down on some orderflow activity
and you know let you decide which one
you think is better so before I begin
you know be sure to subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already you know
we're trying to post a new video up
every day and you know like and comment
on the video
all right so you know one of the
questions I got recently was concerning
you know Mees versus es you know which
one is better obviously there's there's
a big difference in in contract size you
know the
micro e minis U the M you know trades at
a much smaller contract size relative to
the es um they both trade very good
volume and you know honestly the way I
treat them both is you I treat them as
as separate contracts in terms of
trading if I'm trading the mees I'm only
looking at the mees for trading es I'm
only following what's happening in the
es of course I do will look at to see
you know what's going on but there's not
going to be much discrepancy you know
there are people that trade the mees
versus the es and Arbitrage uh those
opportunities when you know when it's
out of line but to be honest it's very
rarely you know out of line more than a
tick and if it gets more than a tick
it's brought back into line really quick
but from an orderflow standpoint right
when you're looking at the volumes in
the the order flow obviously there's
going to be uh big discrepancies but
again you know based on the volume
that's going through on the mees you can
trade it as its own creature by itself
based off what you're seeing in that
order flow and you know some people say
well Mike shouldn't I just follow the
big one since that's the main contract
you know that the market is following
you know the mees is sort of following
it well yeah you could um you know
obviously you don't want to
be getting into to a position you know
sort of opposite to what's happening in
the big ones but again what you're
seeing in the mees is also taking place
in the es okay so this is again today is
the 2nd of uh January so right there's
no trading today you know the
interesting thing about you know a
little trading tidbit is you know
January 1st is really the the only day
that the markets are closed now again I
I can't remember if India is opened or
closed on New Year's Day but you know
even during Christmas the Japanese
markets are are still open on Christmas
day I've remember I've been in the
office trading on Toom right Tokyo
commodity exchange
on Christmas day but New Year's is
really the the one
holiday around the world that you know
every market is closed so we'll reopen
tomorrow uh the 3 and again we'll see
what's going to happen right we had that
big late rally on uh Friday so this is
Friday's order flow in both the this is
the on this side here on the left side
is the mees on the right side here is es
and just really quick right just looking
at this low that was made just after 832
now this is a eight range chart because
you know I had gotten another question
um someone asking me you know what's a
good range based chart to use for ES or
Mees and I like to use an eight range
but you could also use a 10 range I
think a four range or five range is too
fast for the uh Equity markets right the
the es or Mees and I think uh you know 8
to 10 is sort of my sweet spot in terms
of uh analyzing the order flow all right
so this was that low at 8326
8326 and you can just see how the
volumes are different obviously um you
know where the point of control is
coming in you know is a tick difference
I mean the low is still 38 38 and a
quarter on both markets point of
controls on the mees is com at 38 38
and2 on the uh es it's coming in a tick
higher at uh 38 and 3/4 um one of the
noticeable differences is you have this
thin volume in here as the market starts
shooting back up right on the E on the
mees right whereas on the es you just
sort of got your normal volume okay um
you know they both have you know
positive Delta obviously the volume on
the es is slightly more this work out a
little bit bit different here if you're
just looking at the way the volumes are
on these bars at that low on the es it's
uh 25,000 contracts on the mees it's
1,297 but the bar before it on the es
it's only got
852 whereas the bar just before it on
the mees has uh 1,800 so while the bar
on the low has got a th000 less on the
mees it's got a th000 more on the bar
before it again you know semantics but
again there's enough volume going
through on the mees just to trade it on
its own okay now where it got a little
bit interesting is when the market
started moving away from that low now
these are both eight range charts so on
the mees right
83316 we had nice stacked buy and
balance
83314 you don't have a stacked buying
and balance on the es though you do have
two imbalances then in the next bar you
got an imbalance uh coming in you know
where what it should have been in on the
previous bar but you have a stacked
balance so if you're trading stacked
imbalances you had a nice trade here
okay you got another stacked
inbalance a little bit later
83335 83335 there's no stacked inbalance
on the es okay then you get up to that
High um at around 54 the bar right
before it on the es you got nice you
know big stacked buy and balance pretty
much the whole bar is whereas on the
mees it's it's kind of split between the
two bars okay so you know which one's
better well again it it it's not a
matter of well I should be trading this
Market or I should be trading that
market if you're trading the mees you
focus on the mees it's got enough
volume to trade right on its own I mean
compare that to say uh you know
eurocurrency right people trade
eurocurrency Futures by
itself okay and you know and compare
that you know the volume just going back
you know the volumes you're seeing in
here you know 342 238 you know if you
hit a bar on an - range chart in the
eurocurrency of a th000 contracts that's
a lot on the mees is doing a th000 even
more than a th000 no problem okay so
it's it's enough to trade on its own you
don't have to necessarily follow the big
ones and take the trade in the micros if
you know you don't have enough money in
in your account to to fund a a big one
right you could just trade the Mees on
its own you're just going to get
different signals but what you're
looking for in the orderflow is still
going to be the same right now I do get
I do understand people's arguments that
well you know the moves are going to be
trer in the es well yeah they
they the moves are going to be the same
right it's not like Mees is going to
Rally uh 10
ticks while the the es is is selling off
it's just not cuz the the Algos are
going to bring it back in line really
quick cuz again you know while it may be
off by a tick on the bid and the offer
right there's going to be times where
say the bid is you know a quarter bid at
a half in
the mees whereas the the big ones might
be even bid at a half or you know even
bid at a quarter but that those
discrepancies aren't going to last very
long right they're going to be brought
in line and you know a lot
of Traders you know they they don't
really haven't been exposed to many
other markets other than you know the
markets in the US but Japan and
Singapore right Japan the nikai was 10
Yen whereas of Singapore it was you know
a 5 Yen spread so while the Niki might
be
18,820 bid at 30 in Osaka on Singapore
it'd be a quarter bid or 25 bid at 30
right so there was those Arbitrage
opportunities in between especially you
know that that's one of the
the excuses that you know Nick Leon used
in bearings is you know he's taking
advantage of these Arbitrage
opportunities you know it would be 25
bid at 30 in Singapore but the trader in
Japan knows he's going to be selling you
know the 20s in Japan and the 10 so
they're just go in and whack everything
at uh you know 25 20 15 in Singapore but
I said with the mees now with electronic
tradings and and these alos they really
bring all that together
um and keep it tight spread right so
it's not really out of whack very often
but sort of what I want to get into a
little bit today is talking about
imbalances okay
and you know I I've I like talking about
imbalances because you know imbalances
is something that you know a lot of
Traders now are really starting to pay
attention to and it's good because
you know anytime you have a market
that's out of
balance that's where good opportunities
arise and you know let's just sort of go
back here this so this is
my e mini chart here let's go back to
this low the low of the day here at 21
because if you remember on Friday right
we had a huge uh you know a big rally
off this low from you know 21 you know
closing all the way up above uh close to
70 we Clos around 68 but off this low
here
where was it here it's 12 something
1225 okay just pull up the mees at that
time as
well so this is an eight range
chart okay because what you're going to
see is some similar activity here again
same same but different okay so you know
at the low right 34 contracts traded in
the mees and the big 32 okay then
started rallying right and on this move
up um you don't see any stacked
imbalances here right early on right
and you Trend trading is is one of the
easiest ways to take advantage of the
market right if you get in on a trend
early and one of the signs for getting
in on a trend is imbalances in the
market but you have to have a move to
sort of to reverse to catch that Trend
right and you know at the low of the day
and again like I always say you know
you're at the low of the day you want to
be looking for a reason to be getting
long if it's there right don't go
fishing for reasons it should be
something just sticking you in the
poking you in the eye saying hey you
know look at this and um imbalances is
something that I'm always looking at in
the order flow when you're at the low
I'm looking for buying imbalances okay
I'm looking for the market to move off
this low and and you know we got on the
bar at the low one buying imbalance well
first we'll start with we'll start with
the mees okay so yeah you know going
into the lows there's some selling
imbalance stack selling imbalance here
but on the way back up right there's
there's no imbalances till you get all
the way up here to 35 1/2 okay well you
just rallied from 21 1/2 all the way up
to 35 1/2 so it's already a a 14-point
move you know is there something in here
that could have told you hey you know
what there's strong aggressive of buying
and and there is if you
know if you look at the imbalances and
what I've done over the years is
I've realized that imbalances in a bar
whether you know they don't have to be
stacked right Everyone likes looking at
stacked imbalances okay and saying well
yeah because that's very visual you got
one two three stacked on top neatly of
each other but what I've learned and you
know what I've taught over the years and
now I'm starting to see it in the put in
other software thank goodness finally is
what I call multiple imbalances right
bars that have you know three or more
buying and balances you know Green
candles for a bullish signal or you know
three or more selling imbalances and red
candles for bearish signal and right
here as this Market is coming up off the
low I've got 1 two 3 four five here okay
and we even callor the top of the bar um
green but again you don't have to right
it
but knowing that you have that
aggressive buying coming in just
something visual to sort of whack you in
the side of the head said hey don't miss
this opportunity you know aggressive
buyers are stepping in right because
remember we just had a very strong
selloff you reached a low
level and now you know buyers are
stepping up basically saying hey you
know what
um get long right everyone is coming in
and getting long okay
okay but if if your software isn't
highlighting that to you you're going to
easily easily miss that and that's why
you know using tools that's available to
you you know software can do a lot of
things so it's something as simple as
telling you hey you know what you got
multiple imbalances here that's why we
even put the little trigger there um
it's going to give you that edge because
everyone's waiting for that stacked
buying imbalance to come in doesn't come
in until you know 35 A2 36 whereas here
it's telling you you know good Five
Points lower the aggressive buyings
already coming in cuz look at that this
is already a good portion of that move
up okay so that's on the mees right on
the es same thing but it's coming in the
bar off the low all right here it came
in you know the low one two 3 four five
bars off the low again this is an eight
range chart now it's coming in on the
bar immediately after the low right
there right then we just highlight it
really quick again you know and and I I
try to do these videos and keep them
simple with the basic orderflow chart
and I I really feel like I'm missing out
on teaching you guys a lot because you
know orderflow there's so it's so robust
there's really a lot of information that
you can use right and you know people
that aren't using orderflow I think are
the ones that are going to be left
behind in 2023 because you know I've
been working with um you know more
advanced programmers on stuff that you
know they're putting putting this into
um you know more and more sophisticated
trading models so on the regular the es
right the bar afterwards right you're
not even waiting till get to your
stacked imbalances um well the mes had
it up here at you know 35 look at this
it's giving you a chance to get in you
know off the low at 25 20 you at 26
anywhere in this bar or this
bar and that's a quick 10 points
up okay then you know obviously we
started coming back down then we got
that big monster rally and again you
know with that big rally that happened
late in the
day right what sort of the signs are you
got stacked imbalance here but your
multiple buying imbalances are coming in
here okay people say well what about
these selling imbalances here you know
okay maybe you thought the move up was
over in here but then it reverses right
here with a nice bullish signal to catch
the rest of the move back up so again
you know Mees versus es trade them as
their
own unique Market you don't have to sit
there and analyze the es to trade the
mees you could honestly you could trade
the mees as its own I do um and you know
because a lot of the same a lot of what
you're looking for in the es you're
going to also look for in the mees
anyway and maybe about 75% of the time a
lot of the things that you're seeing in
the es is going to appear anyway in the
mees so when you're looking at
imbalances again look for those bars
that have the multiple buying imbalances
off of the low right that that was the
whole point of this exercise today he
talking about the bars that have
multiple buying imbalances off of the
low okay right because again you're
looking at structure you're at a low is
the market telling you buy me all right
if at the high of the day you'd be
looking for reasons to sell it and one
of the clearest obvious reasons to sell
off of a high is aggressive selling and
in the form of imbalances in the market
just as if you're buying off a low one
of the sure signs is aggressive buying
off of buying imbalances all right
everyone so I hope you enjoyed that
video again be sure to like And
subscribe the channel um you know keep
those comments coming you know do read
them my wife thinks I have to repite
every single one I try to get to them
but uh you know enjoy and you hope you
guys have a great 2023 in trading
bye-bye